[Music]
hi everyone my name is Akshay Ram I'm a
product manager here at Google Cloud I'm
joined today with Naman Naman you want
to introduce yourself hi everyone I'm
Naman Shah product manager for Maria DB
Sky sequel So today we're super excited
to talk to you about stateful
applications and kubernetes let's get
started
so for today we're going to first take a
look at stateful applications on Google
kubernetes engines where you'll see the
kind of applications customers are
deploying as well as the value
propositions they get from deploying
these applications on gke
uh second we're going to look at how gke
and kubernetes is actually evolving to
be a place to modernize stateful
applications you look you get a sense of
the capabilities and the features that
both of these platforms offer uh then
we'll take a look at sky SQL skysql from
mariadb is a fully managed DB SAS which
is essentially a very managed product
for you to operate databases and you'll
also learn on how that's deployed on gke
underneath the hood and finally we'll
take a look at a little bit of a demo
so today if you look at stateful
applications uh on gke and kubernetes in
general there's a rising Trend uh there
was a recent survey by the data on
kubernetes community where over 70
percent of customers said they run some
sort of stateful apps on kubernetes
today uh and if we took a look at you
know what are the kind of custom apps
customers are running on gke turns out
it's The Usual Suspects here it's the
databases like MySQL mariadb postgres
SQL it's the caches like redis it's also
messaging cues uh like Kafka so if you
take a click further into the stateful
apps and we spoke with customers and say
hey how are you operating these stateful
apps turns out that three operating
models here the first is customers who
run applications by themselves it's a
do-it-yourself model uh operate it this
way customers take the radius mariadb or
postgres container image and deploy it
in their own compute infrastructure and
they manage both the stateful
application and the underlying
infrastructure so it gives you a lot of
control so it's like a self-managed
operating model so let's say you're
deploying kubernetes on premises you can
use this kind of operating model to
deploy where you have all the control
but then Along Came more customers who
said hey uh you know self-manage is too
much work I'd like more uh shared
responsibility where I can share some of
this work with the operator of an
application and that's where kubernetes
operators come in kubernetes operators
give you a shared responsibility model
can a partially managed kind of
operating model a good example here is
elastics Eck operator where you can
share responsibility of operating
elasticsearch with elastic the company
itself so you have a licensing contract
and you share that a load of of managing
that application
finally at the last end of the spectrum
there's the fully managed SAS Solutions
so to you as customers it's like an end
point where you essentially have a fully
managed database for you you don't have
to manage any of it but these SAS
Solutions are running on gke examples
here are Maria DB Sky SQL and they are
large multi-tenant stateful applications
that are underneath the hood running on
gke so we have taken a look at this
spectrum of applications and the kind of
applications that are running on gke
let's take a look at why customers run
these applications on gke
so we asked DIY customers where do you
run on gke the first point was hey uh
gke gives us a lot of out of the box
orchestration if we were to operate this
on VMS today customers told us that it
actually would need them to do a lot of
work in in terms of building CI CD
building config s code stateful
Primitives you get that all out of the
box with kubernetes and gke so that's
something they want to leverage uh in
the second this is actually a really
important one and it comes up a lot is
organizational gravity think of the sun
you know bending space time and kind of
attracting a lot of other planet centers
orbit what is happening with kubernetes
analogous to that is kubernetes is
gaining so much organizational gravity
that all applications are being
attracted into that operational model so
customers have economies of scale in
their expertise and they don't have
silos of operating State full
application separately and stateless
applications separately because now they
have a unified operational model with
kubernetes and finally ecosystem
ecosystem is important as you saw there
are already a large number of operators
on kubernetes today uh so this is
continuing to grow and one of the
reasons customers choose uh kubernetes
for their stateful applications
now why do the SAS customers choose to
run on gks ask customers are these large
services that provide value to their end
users and the first one is is a really
important one is multi-cloud
infrastructure so the need to run
anywhere is essentially a Salient
feature of these SAS products they run
across clouds it's a you need to have
the SAS wherever you're running so
that's why they choose kubernetes as a
place to run their stateful applications
second is these SAS businesses if you
think about it they're offering very
modern solutions for their end users so
they want to be built on Modern
internals and they want all the built-in
capabilities that gke and kubernetes
offers so that's something that they
really value and finally this is a
little bit of softer value propagation
but it's really important is empathy a
lot of the SAS customers are running
kubernetes itself and and the SAS
customers running their entire platform
on kubernetes kind of builds that shared
vocabulary and language that they can
have with customers and that builds
empathy with their end users
so we have taken a look at the kind of
stateful applications the value prop
list double click and and see why gke in
terms of the features it offers is
actually a platform for modern stateful
applications
but first let's start with customers uh
what did customers tell us like you know
what where can we where can we do better
uh the first one was customers are like
hey uh state kubernetes has an upgrade
cycle that is much different to where I
operate today so if I'm a customer
coming from virtual machines I control
my upgrade Cycles but kubernetes is
upgrading all the time so customers are
like hey can I have safety controls so I
said I can control upgrades and ensure
the rollout of my application is safe so
and stateful applications have to not
have downtime the data needs to be
retained so all of these safety controls
they want built in that was one specific
ask from customers the second one is
sure there's some features in kubernetes
and gke but can you do more for stateful
applications I want more TurnKey
operations for stateful so kind of build
more for us is something that we heard
from customers and finally customers
wanted to start and end with kubernetes
kubernetes is their operating model so
they wanted it all of the storage the
gcp storage to be provisioned in a very
container native way to allow customers
to easily operate storage through the
container interfaces
so this is where we went to the drawing
board and we came up with what cke
should be as a modern platform for
stateful applications the lowest layer
you see is essentially the storage layer
that's where we build storage
Integrations with all of the gcp
products on storage paid persistent disk
Cloud file store and local SSD and the
second layer is essentially where we
build value Edition where we call it the
stateful management platform where
customers get more and more out of the
box features to kind of operate their
stateful application in more a turnkey
fashion and of course the the apps
finally run on top of gke that's the
layer on top
so let's take a look uh deep dive we'll
start with a stateful layer first the
first one is essentially backup for gke
backup for GK is fully managed and what
it gives you as a customer is you can
essentially control what you want to
backup whether it's your kubernetes
cluster or your storage which is running
its persistent volumes you can
completely backup anything you want you
have extensive IIM control to
essentially have some sort of model of
control who can actually back up your
data because data is valuable and
finally you can restore it in different
clusters same clusters it gives you all
of that flexibility so this is
essentially a feature in gke at the
stateful management layer which offers
you a lot of benefits let's take a look
at some of those benefits uh one is of
course you can roll back very easily as
you're rolling out new applications you
can always roll back to previous
versions you know because you've backed
up your data you have that peace of mind
and you can handle zonal and Regional
failure as well because you've backed up
your data you can essentially restore it
in a separate zone for example you
obviously have a place to go back to
when you're when you're upgrading
application because you have that peace
of mind saying hey I've backed up my
data my application is backed up I can
deploy a new version even if there's
something wrong I can go back and
finally there's obviously data archival
for more compliance purposes if your
Regulators need you to keep store copies
of your data so the second page now
we're taking a look at backup for gke in
that stateful management layer let's
take a look at some of the upgrades and
as customers did say upgrades is an is
an important area where they want us to
kind of help them so we built a lot of
extensive controls for safe rollout of
stateful applications on gke the first
one is obviously you have maintenance
and exclusion Windows maintenance
Windows like let's say you have a Black
Friday sale coming up and you say don't
upgrade during these this kind of uh
window and we'll absolutely respect that
and we want and even if you upgrade like
we have a lot of safety in terms of how
we roll out software we have built-in
blue green deployments that basically
means as new versions of software is
rolled out we'll make sure your old
version is ready and healthy and
available and you only roll to new
versions only when you check that it's
actually healthy so you get that safe
way of rolling out new software and
kubernetes itself has a lot of
capabilities and I think one of the most
important when it comes to stateful
application in the spot disruption
budgets where kubernetes gives you the
control to say how much your parts can
be disrupted
finally the last piece of stateful
management in this layer is we have a
lot of other capabilities the first is
gke autopilot fully supports stateful
applications today so gke autopilot
gives you a lot out of the box in terms
of node Management in terms of applying
best practices to your clusters out of
the box by default so you can use that
to simplify operating stateful
applications the second is we we're
always working to build more
observability for customers to better
observe their stateful applications so
what we have is a bunch of out of the
box metrics and we also have full
Integrations with Google managed
Prometheus for all of you who love prom
ql you can use promptql with Google
manage Prometheus to kind of organize
your metrics and last but not the least
we really want to lead the open source
Community here to make stateful
applications well we have leadership in
six storage and we really want to help
the community build or make kubernetes a
great place for stateful applications
so we have taken a look at all of the
store the the the stateful management
layer let's take a look at the last
layer which is storage uh this is this
is super simple here you have choices an
extensive selection uh you can choose
between Cloud file store Cloud file
service Regional back persistent storage
is great for Content Management Systems
uh media streaming even some AIML
analytics we're starting to sing run on
file store you have persistent disks
which is extremely price performant also
persistent storage for you it's sonal
but you also have a read-only regional
repd which is a read-only uh Regional
persistent disk also available for you
if you want that additional redundancy
and this is usually used for databases
message queues and Cloud ID is and
finally we have local ssds which is more
like a ephemeral storage and that's
mostly used for AIML and analytics to
kind of download and process data all of
these are behind a native container
storage interface so it's available for
you out of the box
uh so let's take a look at use cases and
takeaways the use cases of course of all
of these features we saw of course
there's monitoring and troubleshooting
you have that out of the box it's all
built-in storage metrics you have fully
managed automation you can leverage GK
autopilot to even benefit from scaling
from node management from the best
practice of your cluster all applied for
you you have really safe rollout control
strategies customers said they wanted to
be safe you have plenty of safety
controls and finally you get all of
these under a single unified umbrella of
kubernetes to kind of unify that
operation and build that gravity that I
was talking about earlier
so we have taken a look at a lot of
things in terms of the stateful
application layer the storage layer the
capabilities and features now what are
the takeaways the takeaways is first day
two Ops is actually a day one problem I
can't emphasize this enough data
operations is where customers actually
face a lot of pain and there are a lot
of decisions you make on when you when
you start provisioning applications that
can hurt you or or benefit you in in day
two so make sure you make those
decisions well set up the best practices
of upgrade and all of those decisions
which really matter if your application
your observability
uh second is you have a extensive
storage selection on gks choose one that
best suits your needs you want to choose
file store persistent disk local ssds
make that evaluation based on your
application types speak to your
application teams uh third is you want
to either choose DIY or SAS depending on
the amount of control like you can have
a fully managed SAS which we're going to
learn about Maria DB Sky SQL next or you
can do it yourself so you there's a lot
of control while doing it yourself so
definitely consider SAS if you can if
you don't want all that control and this
is the last takeaway of this part of the
presentation is gke is really evolving
and we are committed to investing in
making it a safe place for running
modern stateful applications and and
you'll see this story get better and
easier for customers going forward with
that I'm going to hand it over to Naman
who's going to talk about Maria Davis
sky SQL number you want to take it away
yes absolutely thank you Akshay that was
very insightful
Maria DB is the world's leading open
source database and Sky SQL is mariadb
corporation's fully managed database as
a service platform
skysql enables a wide variety of
transactions analytics and hybrid
database workloads and offers both
multi-cloud and hybrid cloud deployments
combining the unique features in our
products with Cloud infrastructure and
automations
we are able to bring massive scale while
ensuring higher availability for the
most Mission critical applications for
our customers
with slas up to 99.995 and our
experienced DBA by your side with the
skydba add-on Sky SQL is the most
reliable way to run mariadb databases in
the cloud
and since skysql is built on kubernetes
robust sale filling capabilities further
enhance our service availability and
resiliency
now let me quickly introduce you all the
mariadb products that are available in
Sky SQL
starting off we have mariadb Enterprise
server it's an enhanced version of
mariadb community server and brings
Enterprise reliability stability and
long-term support
it is built on years of community
Innovation and offers Enterprise great
features to our customers
next up is mariadb expand expand is our
sophisticated distributed SQL database
providing massive scale and higher
availability without compromising on
consistency
expand uses a shared nothing
architecture bringing near linear read
write scaling for modern applications
mariadb column store is a distributed
columnar database suitable for deploying
modern data warehouses for analytics on
massive data sets
and finally we have mariadb Max scale
which is our intelligent database proxy
providing automatic failover read write
splits and data security
skysql delivers all these products in a
single platform in such a way that you
can easily and securely deploy and
immediately realize the feature richness
of mariadb products
you can start small with a single
mariadb Enterprise server
and add replicas as your needs evolve
and if your app needs even extreme scale
for both reads and writes you could
switch to expand
and also features columnar indexing
capability so you can also support
in-app analytics in real time
or maybe you could use column store for
full analytics and work easily with
extreme volumes
so as you can see while these are
purpose built engine for Unique workload
requirements we present these to our
users in a much more unified manner
and intuitive Sky SQL portal to launch
and manage your services
a rich set of apis and related tooling
to bring Sky SQL in your automations
a single SQL dialect for app developers
to use
in a unified system
to Monitor and administer for the Ops
Team
all these combined with the sensible
defaults we have baked in Sky SQL with a
deep understanding of the databases and
consistent configurations across engines
result in a reduced complexity for our
customers
a user's transition from stitching
diverse and often disjointed databases
to using a simple unified database
service
so how did we build Sky SQL well just
like how our customers rely on Sky SQL
to reduce their database complexity we
rely on gke to reduce our infrastructure
complexities
as you can see all core components of
Sky SQL are deployed in gke
and even our customer database services
are also deployed in kubernetes clusters
you'll find mariadb users everywhere
they are on Prem they are on public and
private clouds big and small
kubernetes gives us the ability to
support multi-cloud deployments and
enables us to cater to our customers
across clouds
running on gke also allows us to
leverage some of the features for
stateful applications that Akshay
mentioned to manage our infrastructure
with ease and frequently and predictably
release updates to Sky SQL
we're seeing more and more of our
customers running their applications on
kubernetes and running Sky SQL on GK
helps us build the same vocabulary and
Architectural familiarity with our
customer
operationally GK also enables us to very
easily manage and upgrade hundreds of
our clusters and their control planes
our SRE teams extensively use the GK UI
and API to manage our global workloads
so that's all I wanted to cover for
today now let's see Sky SQL in action
welcome to Sky SQL demo getting started
with Sky SQL is super easy
click Start free on mariadp.com
and sign in using your email or
preferred identity provider
let me sign in using my mariadb account
Sky SQL comes in two tiers foundation
and Power
Foundation tier provides a great entry
point into skysql
power tier adds more powerful resources
Advanced configuration and Security
Options
as you can see I'm logged in here as a
power tier user
now let's take a look at how you have
launch a service in Sky SQL
you can start by selecting either
transactions or analytics service
in a single or multi-node configuration
replicated topology is based on mariadb
Enterprise server
we offer up to five read replicas read
write splitting and automated Split
Second failover for higher availability
our distributed topology is powered by
mariadb expand
it provides extreme read write scale and
higher availability without compromising
on asset level consistency
you can start at three nodes and scale
out to 21 notes or more on Sky SQL
combines the power of mariadb column
store and low cost object storage
you can launch a distributed data
warehouse with massively parallel
processing capabilities using this
service
now let's try to launch a single node
transaction service
I'm going to select Google Cloud
and select Us East one as my region
an important thing to note here is that
our power to your users get a dedicated
kubernetes cluster providing them a very
high level of isolation
a star next to the region indicates that
there is already an existing cluster
uh let's select an instance size and
storage that best meets our workload
requirement
um let's give this service a name
review the estimated charges
and hit launch
now this is going to take a few minutes
so what I've done is I've already
pre-launched a few services
there is one for each of the topologies
if I expand on the service card you'll
see that it offers a convenient way to
manage your services
you can see the service parameters
configuration details an estimated
charges right here
you can also see the connection details
and get additional various service
options right here
all right now let's go ahead and connect
to these services
to connect you can either use Maria
dbcli or one of the supported
third-party clients
I'm going to use table Plus
what I have done here is that I have
preloaded all these three databases with
us flight data since 2015.
you know there are some 50 million
records of commercial flight travel data
if you're migrating your data from
either on-premo Cloud we do offer
convenient self-service replication
options
all right so let's try to run a few
simple queries on the replicated
database
now let's try the same one on the
distributed transactions
and finally on the analytics database
so what you can see here is that while
each of these databases are running on
purpose built engines applications can
query the data using a single SQL
dialect that is extremely powerful
all right so now let's try to run a
complex analytical query involving
several joints and aggregations on our
analytics database
this is going to take a few seconds but
I wanted to remind that this query is
running on some 40 million records on
the smallest size single node column
store instance in Sky SQL
quite impressive right
cool let's go back to Sky SQL
Sky SQL monitoring provides a single
pane class of view across all your Sky
SQL services
our monitoring tool collects metrics at
both database node and cluster level and
presence to users in a series of
dashboard
so you can see here range of metrics
being displayed
there are several system level metrics
also CPU load memory usage disk logs i o
activities so on and so forth
we also have an alerts too
which provides a pre-configured set of
alerts
to alert the users on important event
that require their attention
there is also logs archive area which
gives you access to customer
configurable error logs low query logs
and edit logs
now while Sky SQL is configured by
default for Optimal Performance data
protection and security we do have a
configuration manager which allows you
to create custom configuration that meet
your database requirements
finally we have handy links to Sky SQL
support and documentation right here
this is my demo of skysql feel free to
try out sky SQL at your convenience
visit mariadb.com and start your free
trial today thank you
so that concludes the demo for Sky
sequel sign up on Maria db.com and take
advantage of the trial credit thank you
very much
thank you everyone
[Music]